Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Je suis particulièrement heureuse d’avoir
été invitée à vous parler ici ce soir
puisque nous sommes
le lendemain du 8 mars.
Hier, c’était la journée internationale
du droit des femmes
et ça ne vous aura pas échappé,
nous avons parlé des femmes.
Eh bien je vais continuer
dans les dix prochaines minutes
à vous parler des femmes.
Mais avant ça, je dois
vous faire une confidence.
Je m’appelle Laura
et jusqu’à mes seize ans,
j’ai détesté ce prénom.
J’aurais voulu m’appeler Victoire,
Jade, Joana ou même Alexandra.
Et puis un jour, un peu par hasard,
j’ai appris que mes parents
m’avaient nommée ainsi
parce qu’en hébreu,
Laura voulait dire lumière.
Et là, tout s’est éclairé.
Mon prénom prenait enfin du sens.
J'ai fini par doucement l'apprivoiser.
Quelques années plus tard, un été,
j’étais en vacances
et je faisais un exercice d’introspection,
de développement personnel,
celui de l’ikigai,
qui consiste à croiser quatre cercles
dont le dénominateur commun
serait votre raison d’être,
votre mission de vie.
En recoupant les différentes données,
je découvris que ma mission de vie à moi
était la suivante :
exposer ma lumière au monde
et faire briller celle des autres
autour de moi.
Tiens !
Le sens de mon prénom se trouvait
dans ma mission de vie.
Étrange coïncidence.
Mais je ne crois pas vraiment au hasard.
La lumière, vous savez, elle est partout :
en vous,
même quand vous pensez
qu’elle est éteinte depuis longtemps,
en moi, en votre voisin, voisine,
à côté de qui vous êtes assis ici ce soir,
et même en votre pire ennemi.
Mais la réalité, c’est que la lumière
des femmes, particulièrement,
elle a longtemps été cachée,
comme si on avait essayé de l’éteindre.
Et puis, quand les femmes
sont quand même mises en lumière,
ce n’est pas toujours
pour les bonnes raisons.
Et pire,
quand l’opportunité leur est donnée
de vraiment prendre la lumière,
la plupart des femmes s’en détournent.
En créant mon podcast
et en recevant plus de 200 femmes,
en écrivant mon livre
sur le féminisme éclairé,
je me suis aperçue qu’on avait
longtemps essayé de cacher,
voire d’éteindre la lumière des femmes.
À bien des égards, les femmes ont été
et sont encore aujourd’hui
invisibilisées de nos époques.
Et cette invisibilisation
s'observe partout.
Prenons un exemple dans les sciences.
Nombre de femmes ont vu leur nom
passé sous silence
alors qu’elles étaient l’objet
de contributions scientifiques
absolument majeures.
En 1962, James Watson,
Francis Crick et Maurice Wilkins
reçoivent le prix Nobel de la médecine
pour leur découverte
de la structure de l’ADN.
Mais Rosalind Franklin voit son nom
passé sous silence
alors qu’elle a très largement contribué
à cette découverte.
Mileva Einstein,
l’épouse du très célèbre génie
dont nous parlions tout à l’heure,
reprenait, complétait, corrigeait
régulièrement ses travaux.
Pourtant, faute de preuves, le rôle
de Mileva dans les découvertes d’Albert
est très largement,
encore aujourd’hui, sous-estimé.
Je pourrais continuer
en vous parlant d’Ada Lovelace,
mathématicienne à l’origine
du premier programme informatique,
ou encore de Margaret Hamilton,
qui a créé le programme qui a permis
d’envoyer le premier homme sur la Lune.
Ce phénomène d’absence de reconnaissance
des femmes dans les sciences
est tellement connu qu’il porte un nom :
l’effet Matilda.
En hommage à la militante féministe
américaine du XIXᵉ siècle,
Matilda Joslyn Gage,
qui s’était aperçue
que les femmes étaient très souvent
dépossédées de leur contribution.
Tout autre registre : notre urbanisme.
Autour de vous, autour de nous,
dans les rues de Paris,
le nom des rues de Paris,
les squares, les jardins, les places,
les monuments, les statues
sont quasiment toutes à l’effigie
de figures héroïques masculines.
Dans l’art :
la Base Joconde,
qui a pour objectif de recenser l’ensemble
des œuvres présentes dans les musées,
a démontré qu’au musée du Louvre,
sur les 3000 peintures exposées,
seulement 40 étaient signées
par des femmes.
En réalité, ça commence très tôt,
parce que dès la cour de récréation,
la mixité est l’exception.
La structure très répandue des cours
de récréation avec un terrain de foot
fait que les garçons occupent
une place centrale.
Les filles sont reléguées au coin.
Elles sont nombreuses,
mais on ne les voit pas.
Et dans les dessins d’enfants,
on voit que les filles sont représentées
soit dans les coins, soit dans les
toilettes, des endroits cachés ou privés.
À y regarder de plus près,
on se rend compte
que de l’ombre à la lumière,
pouf !
les femmes disparaissent.
Je vais prendre quelques exemples,
certes généraux,
mais vous allez voir qu’ils reflètent
une réalité encore bien présente.
Traditionnellement, à l’ombre
des foyers et des maisons,
qui prépare les plats,
nourrit la famille, cuisine ?
Encore en majorité les femmes.
Mais à la lumière des étoiles
et de la reconnaissance internationale,
qui sont les chefs très talentueux
qu’on acclame ?
Pour l’immense majorité, des hommes.
Au niveau également de la mode
qui habituellement, encore une fois,
recoud, tricote, rapièce, répare ?
Qui sont les petites mains
à l’ombre des grands défilés ?
Pour beaucoup, des femmes.
Mais sur les podiums des Fashion Weeks,
qui sont les grands créateurs acclamés ?
Les très talentueux Marc Jacobs,
Jean-Paul Gaultier, Karl Lagerfeld,
Yves Saint Laurent.
Des hommes.
Je pourrais continuer en vous disant
qu’on va plus facilement
prêter une fibre créative, artistique,
décorative aux femmes,
mais que les grands noms
qui ont marqué l’art
s’appellent Picasso, Miro, Chagall,
Degas, Renoir, Van Gogh, Cézanne,
vous les connaissez : des hommes.
De l’ombre à la lumière,
les femmes disparaissent.
Alors, je vous rassure,
je ne suis ni la seule ni la première
à m’être aperçue de ce phénomène.
D'autres avant moi s'en sont rendu compte
et des mesures nécessaires ont été prises
pour voir plus de femmes
au sein des instances de direction,
dans les médias et même dans l’art.
Il y a des progrès, il y a des avancées
et il faut les souligner.
Le problème, voyez-vous,
c’est qu’on ne transforme pas,
on ne change pas une civilisation
et une société à coups de lois.
Les lois créent une contrainte,
elles accélèrent un changement,
elles ouvrent un débat,
mais elles ne transforment pas
les mentalités.
Encore trop de femmes sont absentes
des cellules de savoir et de pouvoir,
comme la philosophie, les sciences,
le numérique ou encore la finance.
Quand une femme prend la parole
ou un poste à responsabilité,
plane encore au-dessus d’elle
une présomption d’illégitimité :
a-t-elle les épaules ?
Les procès en incompétence demeurent.
Les erreurs, c’est prouvé,
sont bien moins acceptées
quand elles sont le fait des femmes
que de leurs homologues masculins.
On le voit aujourd’hui,
de l’ombre à la lumière,
les femmes disparaissent.
Mais ce qu’il se passe également,
c’est que si les femmes sont
un peu plus mises en lumière,
la réalité, c’est que,
pas toutes les femmes.
Des femmes demeurent
encore aujourd’hui invisibilisées.
Et évidemment, la répartition
du travail domestique,
qui a faiblement évolué
ces dix dernières années,
ne contribue pas
à cette visibilisation des femmes.
Comment une femme peut être aussi visible
qu’un homme dans l’espace public
quand elle consacre encore aujourd’hui
plus de 10 h par semaine en moyenne
aux tâches ménagères ?
Nous, les femmes, nous avons beaucoup
de dons, mais pas encore celui d’ubiquité.
Alors parfois la lumière,
elle est là, sur les femmes,
mais elle n’est pas forcément
mise au bon endroit.
Un récent rapport
du Haut Conseil à l’égalité
montrait que 29% des remarques
faites aux femmes
portent sur leur tenue
ou sur leur physique.
Une ministre que j’ai reçue
sur mon podcast me confiait
avoir renoncé à s’apprêter pour ses
prises de parole à l’Assemblée nationale
car quand un journaliste
relayait ses propos,
il commençait quasiment
systématiquement l’article
en commentant sa manucure ou son brushing.
Lorsque les femmes sont invitées
dans les médias,
où elles occupent 33% du temps de parole,
c’est beaucoup plus souvent
en tant que victime ou témoin,
rarement en tant qu’experte.
Et si certaines femmes sont quand même
plus mises en lumière, pas toutes.
Où sont les femmes porteuses de handicap ?
Où sont les femmes victimes de violences,
les femmes issues de minorités,
les femmes qui élèvent un foyer seules,
quand on sait que 80%
des familles monoparentales
sont tenues par des femmes ?
Où sont toutes ces héroïnes du quotidien
que l’on ne voit pas,
que l’on ne regarde pas,
qui ne se montrent pas ?
Alors si on est juste et honnête
face à l’ampleur du phénomène,
la réalité,
c’est que même quand la possibilité
de prendre la lumière leur est donnée,
la plupart des femmes s’exposent moins.
Elles osent moins, elles parlent moins,
elles négocient moins,
elles se montrent moins.
Mais ce n’est pas une fatalité,
car nous avons chacune un levier
et pas des moindres, à notre disposition.
Ce levier, c’est non pas celui
de trouver sa place, mais de la créer.
Le pouvoir ne se donne pas, il se prend.
La parole ne se donne pas, elle se prend.
La lumière ne se donne pas, elle se prend.
Ne restez pas cette bonne élève,
sage, discrète, humble, modeste.
Devenez cette femme qui ose
avancer vers sa lumière.
Évidemment,  ce n’est pas toujours simple.
Comment faire ?
Dotez-vous de cinq armes
de construction massive.
Un :
cultivez votre singularité,
c’est votre plus grande force.
Investissez pleinement vos qualités
plutôt que de chercher à réduire,
à restreindre vos prétendus défauts.
Et pas besoin de mimer
les codes masculins pour réussir.
Soyez vous-même,
les autres sont déjà pris.
Deux :
osez, enfin osez.
La solution est souvent dans l'action.
C'est en osant que l'on devient légitime,
pas l'inverse.
Alors au placard, la crainte
du regard des autres, de l’échec,
du manque de perfection.
Ayez simplement peur de vos futurs regrets
et dites-vous bien que mieux vaut
fait que parfait.
Trois :
acceptez de déplaire.
Nous, les femmes, nous avons été
socialisées pour plaire.
Mais plaire à tous,
c’est ne plaire à personne.
Alors, comme Jean Cocteau le disait,
« Ce qu’on te reproche,
cultive-le parce que c’est toi. »
Ayez le courage de déplaire.
Quatre :
apprenez à parler de vous autrement
qu’en minimisant vos réussites.
Aujourd’hui, une grande partie
de l’impact passe par la parole.
Alors trouvez votre propos,
enthousiasmez-vous
pour ce que vous avez à dire et dites-le.
Passez du savoir-faire au faire-savoir.
Cinq :
cultivez la sororité.
Faites-vous briller les unes les autres
sans craindre de vous faire de l’ombre,
car au contraire, vous nourrirez
ainsi votre propre lumière.
Alors je compte sur vous.
Soyez cette femme qui ose exposer
sa lumière au monde,
car nous avons besoin de vous.
Nous avons besoin de plus
de Christine Lagarde, Jacinda Ardern,
Michelle Obama, Beyoncé,
Niki de Saint Phalle.
Nous avons besoin de ces femmes
qui osent, qui montrent leur lumière.
Parce que vous êtes la lumière.
Je suis la lumière.
Nous sommes la lumière.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)